tonight I'm Brian Ross investigates new
trouble for us a swim as the sport
prepares for next summer's Olympics the
governing body is under criminal
investigation for an alleged cover-up of
sex abuse by its coaches its top
official has refused to answer our
questions and asked under oath
Tim Hinchey admitted he had never even
read the USA Swimming code of conduct as
you sit here today have you ever
reviewed in its entirety USA Swimming
his code of conduct I have not and
conceded he has little understanding
about sexual predators groom their young
victims I'm just not familiar with all
the examples of grooming we're joined by
former Olympic swimming star Nancy
hogshead mocker plus the latest on
president Trump's tax returns what is it
he doesn't want investigators to see all
in surprise winning journalist David Cay
Johnston has the answer and our shoutout
for the Detroit reporter who was the
first journalist to understand just how
serious the FBI investigation of the
United Auto Workers could be it's a big
story in Detroit and we've been staying
on top of it for two years plus from the
law and crime Network studios in New
York City's Herald Square this is Brian
Ross investing
good evening and welcome tonight new
developments in the story that continues
to suggest something very wrong with one
of America's premier sports
organizations USA Swimming which
oversees some 3,000 local clubs with
more than 350,000 young Americans many
of whom shared the dream of one day
winning Olympic gold for their country
no sport has banned more coaches and
staff for sexually abusing young
athletes than USA Swimming yet new
evidence reveals that the person who
runs the USA Swimming organization
professes a surprising ignorance about
some of the basic background and most
important warning signs that could help
protect young swimmers from sexual
predators can you think of any other
national governing body which is banned
proportionally by way of percentage more
members than USA Swimming for sexual
misconduct again I don't know what those
numbers would be Timothy Hinchey is the
CEO and president of USA Swimming and
this is a video of sworn testimony he
gave in a court case in which he and his
sport are accused of covering up sexual
abuse he was questioned by Robert Allard
a lawyer bringing the lawsuit would you
agree that part of keeping the children
in USA swimming safe means doing your
best to protect them from child
molesters yes you would agree sir that
child molestation is a serious thing
true yes
the lawsuit involves the now-closed Swim
Club in Stockton California where the
head swim coats Sony Chi Fuji Zuma
pleaded guilty to the rape and sexual
molestation of a young swimmer beginning
when she was 12 years old
the coach was found to have insidiously
gained her confidence over time what is
known as grooming do you know enough
about grooming sir that it takes place
over time I'm not familiar with the
grooming takes place and when hen she
was shown training material produced by
us swimming itself laying out the
warning signs that predators can display
in grooming victims Hinchey admitted he
had never ever read it in the three
years he has
on USA Swimming this is information
which is disseminated by USA Swimming as
part of its training program is it not I
have not read it before have you ever
assess whether or not pedophiles are
particularly attracted to the sport of
swimming
I have not again and again Hinchey
admitted his lack of knowledge about the
subject I'm just not familiar with all
the examples of grooming again I'm I
don't have the expertise to answer that
I just don't have the expertise as
relates to identify and what grooming is
before I read this information to you
had you been previously made aware of
this information not that I'm reading
today and hich he admitted he was even
unfamiliar with the USA Swimming code of
conduct at any point in time did you
receive any type of training on USA
Swimming code of conduct I did not as
you sit here today have you ever
reviewed in its entirety USA Swimming is
code of conduct I have not
USA Sabine says it relies on a so-called
safe sport program designed to teach
athletes and their parents what to look
for is warning signs of grooming
behavior when Hin G testified before
Congress earlier this year he made much
of the safe sport program we have a
number of new initiatives underway and
we are vetting even more the safe sport
recognized club program will enhance
athlete protection efforts at all levels
especially the local level well we
cannot change the past we will learn
from it and we will do better our
commitment to preventing child sexual
abuse and providing a safe and healthy
environment for athletes is constant and
long-lasting but our investigation found
only a tiny percentage of the 3,000 swim
clubs around the country had actually
been certified in the safe sport program
and when we tried to ask in Chiba at a
fundraiser last year he walked away
refusing to answer
can you tell me right now how many
that's right now but why not why can't
you talk because I'm here hosting people
I know these are important questions sir
sir how many recognize safes sport clubs
exist today can you answer that question
sir in his deposition testimony the
attorney read Hinchey a section of a
report prepared for USA Swimming about
the lack of safe sport program
participation as of this writing only
one-half of one percent of the children
in USA Swimming have taken the safe
sport program period unquote do you see
that idea are you aware of any other
figures which had been calculated since
the time that this document was authored
in 2014 I don't know what the figures
are would you agree that the percentage
of 1/2 of 1% is totally unacceptable
after an objection by his lawyer off
microphone Hinchey finally answered yeah
it's not good and then the attorney
pushed NC to respond to the fact that
the Stockton Swim Club where his client
was molested had no safe sport
coordinator no training of parents no
training of children are you aware of
any monitoring compliance program within
USA Swimming implemented in the last
several years which ensures that members
of clubs such as the Stockton Swim Club
are properly trained on safe sport
materials I'm not aware of any so there
could potentially be hundreds of clubs
out there right now with the same level
of a so-called protection system as
Stockton but you would have no idea
about that there he waits for an
objection and then answers either lying
or safe sport seem to know what the
actual numbers are and how they monetary
whatever the numbers are USA Swimming
clearly did not protect the young woman
who Aled represents for the Stockton
club do you believe that my client was
provided with a safe and healthy
environment for her to grow play and
complete compete
again off-mike the USA Swimming lawyer
quickly objected but then allowed
Hinchey to answer I'm not sure we got no
response to our request for a comment
from USA Swimming as has been their
practice since we first began to report
this story
but joining us now is Nancy hogshead
Makar who won three gold medals and one
silver in the 1984 Summer Olympics is
now an outspoken advocate on behalf of
young athletes swimmers who have been
abused by their coaches Nancy what is
your action to the answers given by CEO
Tim hinge ease his answers and is not
answers
I think it's appalling other than
Michael Phelps and you know Simone
Manuel I don't think that there's any
bigger story dealing with swimming and
all the coaches that they've had that
have been sexually abused his
predecessor Chuck while Gus was kept out
of a Hall of Fame specifically because
how poorly he dealt with the issue of
sexual abuse and here's Hinchey the new
man who hasn't even read the code of
conduct is not familiar of many of the
terms involving grooming of young
athletes which is a key of course to
preventing this kind of sexual abuse of
the young swimmers I would think as a
leader of an organization you would at
least want him he should at least know
what's what's appropriate what's not
appropriate and be able to be conversant
with these terms about what's
appropriate boundaries and what is
grooming behavior things like that
because he's gonna get questions on hey
this happened and for him not to know is
stunning Nancy a question for you from
our control room from the executive
producer Rhonda Schwartz Rhonda what's
your question Nancy do you think there's
something in the culture at USA Swimming
that seems to be preventing this
situation improving what do you say
about that yeah there definitely is
something in the culture because every
athlete every parent everybody in United
States swimming should know starting at
age 7 that coaches shall not have
Mantic and sexual relationships with the
athletes that coach regardless of age or
consent they should know that the that
it is off-limits for a coach to try to
institute any kind of relationship with
somebody that they're coaching in
swimming you have a lot of marriages
that happen when athletes are very young
18 19 20 so it's not criminal conduct
but that that culture grooves the whole
sport to think that it's okay for a
coach to pick they're romantic and
sexual partner from within the athletes
that they coach and they're not willing
to say what I said about right they're
not willing to make it well-known to
everyone that there is this bright-line
rule
Nancy is the Wall Street Journal has
reported there's now a criminal
investigation of USA Swimming a number
of lawsuits now pending going on in
California in North Carolina is that
what it's going to take to stop this you
know you would think that the harm
that's done to these children would be
enough but maybe when there is some
criminal not just investigations but
comes some criminal sentences handed
down maybe that will make swimming
perkupp three years and notice but at
this point you would say for young
people who are part of USA Swimming
there still are not enough protections
in your view yeah your average family
doesn't know what to what to ask a coach
how to hire a coach how to establish
boundaries how to prevent grooming it's
not that hard
indeed well nancy hogshead makar thank
you for joining us very much thank you
for taking this story seriously I
appreciate it you bet up next president
Trump and his income tax returns what is
he hiding we'll talk to the Pulitzer
Prize winning author who may know the
answer when we come back
back now to try to answer the question
of why President Trump is working so
hard to keep his income tax returns
hidden as a candidate he was the first
in decades not to voluntarily make them
public claiming he couldn't do so
because he was being audited I will
absolutely give my return but I'm being
audited now for two or three years so I
can't do it until the audit is finished
obviously and I think people would
understand that but the returns never
were turned over and now the president
is waging a fierce legal battle to keep
them from being turned over to Congress
or to district attorney in Manhattan
sigh Vance who's investigating whether
mr. Trump or his Trump Organization
broke the law when it paid hush money to
two women to keep them from talking
about their relationship with him
joining us now as someone who has a keen
insight into what's happening and why
David Cay Johnston appalled surprise
winning journalist and the author of the
book the making of Donald Trump David
thanks for joining us what is the
president afraid of in these returns do
you think well first and foremost he's
afraid that everyone's going to discover
that his claims of being a billionaire
are nonsense he's a wealthy man but he's
in the tens of millions or hundreds of
millions class not a as he's claimed ten
plus billionaire but more importantly
Donald has a long history of tax
cheating he had two income tax fraud
trials over his 1984 tax returns which
weren't held until the 1990s and in one
of those cases something really
extraordinary happened the judge in one
case handed the tax return that had been
submitted to the government to Donald
Trump's and his father's longtime tax
lawyer and accountant to since retired
and Jack Mitnick testified that's my
signature but I and my firm did not
prepare that tax return and one of the
reasons Donald Trump doesn't want
science to get his hands on the more
recent tax returns prepared by the
majors accounting firm I think there's a
very good chance that what he submitted
to the government doesn't line up with
what was prepared by his accountants so
you reveal in your book that he actually
falsified this returns using the name of
his accountant but putting in his own
numbers
he used a photocopy machine to put the
accountants name onto the tax return my
very first big investigation 45 years
ago was about exactly that somebody
here's the photocopy machine to put
somebody else's name on documents and
that's one of a lot of reasons Donald
needs to be worried you know my former
newspaper the New York Times a year ago
did a 14,000 word investigation which I
could not find a single flaw not even a
technical one about accounting or taxes
or economics and the times didn't
pussyfoot around they said flat out
Donald Trump has committed tax crimes
and when the judicial authorities began
to investigate his sister judge Marianne
Trump berry on the federal bench she
resigned and I'm like you and me and the
people listening where an investigation
would continue the judges have a nice
little rule for themselves when she
resigns they no longer look into her
conduct the president's lawyers have
argued that mr. Vance has no business
getting those tax returns it's going to
go to the Supreme Court it now seems
after the Second Circuit said the
advance should have them what do you
think the Supreme Court is going to rule
well I think the Supreme Court will not
take the case the Donald doesn't have
any claim here it's been the law since
Thomas Jefferson that a president can't
try to subpoena in this way the subpoena
by the way has nothing to do with his
presidency it is for business records
and tax returns before he took office if
the Supreme Court does take the case I
think it will be solely for the purpose
of writing an opinion that slaps down
Trump's assertions that he is exempt
even as his lawyer said in this case
from a criminal inquiry were he to shoot
someone on Fifth Avenue and you think
then the side Vance investigation here
in Manhattan could in fact be a real
threat to president Trump perhaps after
he leaves office oh I think it's a very
significant threat I think there's a
high likelihood it will result in a
criminal charge and if not certainly in
civil actions over his taxes remember
science has access to his state returns
and in New York your state return is
virtual
identical to your federal return and
given Donald's long history of faking
documents losing documents taking the
same circumstances and reporting them in
radically different ways to two
different government agencies to think
that Donald Trump's tax returns is clean
would be naive in the extreme David K
Johnson thank you so much for joining us
tonight fascinating insights thank you
up next our shoutout for the journalist
who has led the way in reporting on the
scandal at the United Auto Workers the
UAW whose president has now taken the
leave after being implicated in a
bribery allegation
back now with our shadow tonight for a
reporter whose work we first highlighted
earlier this year and has been staying
on a story he broke the bribery and
kickback scandals at one of the
country's most powerful and important
unions the United Auto Workers the UAW
and now the Union President Gary Jones
has unexpectedly taken a paid leave as
he was implicated although not yet
charged in the $700,000 bribery scheme
and leading the way in breaking the
story as he has from the beginning
Robert Snell of the Detroit News Detroit
is a union town and the annual Labor Day
Parade is a big event but the news
coverage this year was driven by the
revelation that the city's most powerful
union leader Gary Jones the President of
the United Auto Workers the UAW is the
subject of an FBI investigation of
alleged corruption a story broken by
Robert Snell the Detroit News there were
protesters union workers protesting you
know decrying the corrupt reports of
corruption that have come out of federal
court Gary Jones marched for part of the
parade declined comment to reporters on
the scene and left before the parade was
finished Snell who covers the federal
courts for the Detroit News first
started working on the UAW corruption
story some two years ago yeah there's a
lot of outrage in some circles they were
the workers fear that this is
confirmation of what they've suspected
that some UAW leaders might just be out
for themselves and not for the average
blue-collar worker so far nine people
have been convicted the latest this week
in federal court in Detroit the Union
has sought to portray the convictions as
not that significant I mean I think
we're fairly well sourced with you know
people close to the investigation and
there hasn't been a challenging of any
of the facts what what they have tried
to focus reporters on is that this is
merely a few bad apples who have been
charged and convicted and that this
doesn't represent a broader crisis for
the UAW but this past week Snell and his
colleagues Brianna novo and Ian
Thibodeaux broke the story that the
union president himself
Jones was part of the investigation with
exclusive coverage of an FBI raid on
Jones's home during the search the
investigators had left the garage door
open at Gary Jones home and one of the
neighbors across the street who was
watching this dramatic federal search
unfold grabbed his binoculars and could
see agents in the garage with the open
garage door counting what this neighbor
described as watts of cash really sort
of a dramatic description of what was
unfolding on the scene today federal
agents descended on the homes of some
top officials with one of the nation's
largest unions the raid on the home of
the UAW president was picked up by news
organizations across the country who had
pretty much ignored the story until now
today FBI Special Agents searching
inside the Canton Michigan home of UAW
president Gary Jones it's been somewhat
of a lonely beat once we broke the news
that the FBI and IRS and Labor
Department were you know investigating
and searching multiple locations around
the country the the coverage mushroomed
you know you started to see the
financial wires and pretty much every
major newspaper Wall Street Journal
start to weigh in and cover the
developments from last week the
allegations are reminiscent of the
blatant corruption at the Teamsters
Union something I covered in my early
days as an NBC News correspondent except
now there are a lot fewer reporters
assigned to cover such stories it's
tough in the newspaper industry with you
know fewer resources but thankfully my
editors have stayed committed to the
story for over two years so it's it's a
matter of you know what we're going to
devote resources to and this is like you
said a union town it's a big story in
Detroit and we've been staying on top of
it for two years plus and there's more
to come you think for sure definitely so
a shout out for Robert still at his
colleagues at the Detroit News for
staying on the story which clearly is
far from over
that's our program for tonight thanks
for joining us we'll see you back here
next week good night